because of the explosive popularity of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe people are
more aware than ever of the weirder
characters from the comic canon however
there are a few heroes that will likely
remain on the bench no matter how big
the MCU get heroes like moon Knights
depending on who's writing him he's
either a Batman knockoff or a killer who
talks to a moon god when he's not
already busy talking to his multiple
personalities despite being so strange
moon might still have a cult following
and his fans of clamored for years to
see him appear on the silver screen
alongside Captain America and the gang
but despite the fan love it's a pretty
safe bet that Marvel won't make a moon
night movie he is why risky religion
when it comes to religion the Marvel
Cinematic Universe has traded pretty
lightly outside of Captain America's
take on having a bunch of Norse gods pop
up there's only one god man and I'm
pretty sure he doesn't dress like that
but with moon night it's impossible to
separate the man and his religion such
as it is he draws his powers from the
egyptian moon god khonshu so pretty much
any version of a superhero story would
mean introducing a whole new bunch of
gods to the MCU
we already have our guardians go any
deeper and this law gets a whole lot
more confusing so as the story goes moon
night is the moon God's chosen one and
it becomes a vigilante to do conscious
bidding which sometimes actually
includes murdering the bad guys in case
you were wondering none of this would
really translate to Marvel Cinematic
Universe - well unless it's handled
perfectly it's easy for moonlight to
come across as little more than a
murderous crazy cult member think less
daredevil more Zodiac killer that's not
going to sell too many action figures
redundant one key area where Marvel has
been successful it's making its various
on-screen characters seem distinct it
takes a mix of great casting and making
the right story decisions and for the
most part Marvel is killing it Robert
Downey jr. set the bar pretty high with
Tony Stark and they were careful enough
of Doctor Strange to make sure he didn't
just hit the same rich white guy hero
beep but when it comes to moon nights he
falls into a whole lot of Batman's
territory and in case you haven't
noticed Batman's got a lot of territory
let's see rich guy
mask-wearing vigilante by night lives in
a mansion built over a cave is assisted
by a faithful Butler and users seemed
weaponry to take out bad guys sound
familiar
yes moonlight is obviously more than
just that and have several differences
when more closely compared to Batman but
he checks a whole lot of the same boxes
as The Dark Knight for the average
movie-going audience it would probably
be a few boxes too many now while we're
on the subject of being like Batman too
gimmicky Batman uses a whole lot of gear
and gimmicks but imagine if all those
batarangs were now moon around
is it getting cheesier viewers have had
decades to get used to Batman's brand of
battle injustice but it might be hard to
spring an entire moon gear lineup on
number one heroes typically have a
signature weapon that makes them stand
out think Iron Man's armor or Captain
America's shield but moonlight doesn't
really have that one look at the guy in
action and all audiences can really tell
is that it's kind of all over the place
mental health mental illness is a
delicate subject in general and it gets
even taisiya when it comes to
superheroes after all anyone who puts on
spandex and spends their nights hunting
people must have more than a few screws
loose right oh no I'm just standing
around you know not however moonlight is
established as literally not seen in the
comics on multiple occasions that could
be tough to bring to life on the big
screen in a respectful way a major part
of moonlights madness it's as multiple
personalities the roster ranges from
taxi driver Jake Lockley mercenary marc
spector and even other superheroes like
Spider Man Wolverine and Captain America
at signs they all interact in moonlights
head which would not be easy to portray
in live-action unfortunately if movie
goers aren't ready for a super violent
religious zealot for a hero they're
definitely not ready for an outright
unhinged one that's outfit let's be
honest moon lights costume would be one
of the toughest to make look cool on the
big screen it's true that most superhero
costumes look at least a little goofy in
their original comics but the tried and
true ways of fixing us in a movie
wouldn't work here
the typical move is to make it leather
and make it darker for instance scarlet
witch's bright red spandex became a
maroon jacket
black pants while Hawkeye's purple getup
morphed into a nearly or black outfit on
film but moonlights costume is white
like all whites if they made it darker
it wouldn't be moon night and after a
few bloody fights
that's all white costume would start to
look pretty rough realistically it
spends most of the movie looking like a
super hobo once the action started
better on TV it's been rumored for the
better part of a decade that a
moonlights TV show could happen though
we'd love to see them get to shop at big
screen glory it's obvious the character
would be better served on the boob tube
having an entire season to develop his
character all of them would allow
audiences to suggest the complexities of
all his different personas but simply it
had take a TV season to provide a
breathing room for the villain the
supporting cast and the world-building
necessary to make moon night's work his
character seems tailor-made for Netflix
which already features Marvel
anti-heroes tortured by guilt loss and
trauma then if moon nights doesn't end
up fitting in of Jessica Jones and Luke
Cage at first he can just keep swapping
personalities until he does problem
solved
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know your love to
[Music]